για τη για τα για τις μονάδες μεταμόσχεψης μιελο ναιμα δεν υπάρχει μό νομοθεσία για
πολλά αλλά πράγματα και όμως γίνεται η αυτόλογή μεταμόσχευψη γίνεται παρόλο που δεν υπάρχει νομοθεσία
έχω τη εντύπωση τη διέσθυση ότι ανδεν το εκάναμεν εμείς και το έκαμε κάποιος άλλος
αυτό είναι διαίσθεση δική μυεταν πιο εύκολα τα πράγματα σοβαρύχμία αυτό πάτις γιατρέ ωριστε σοβαρύ
εχμη λέω μηλόγια μια διαίσθυση καμια φορά η ηδιασθυσης δεν πευτικότεέ αόχι απάτοκαι εύχομε να
νι για τρε ο νίκο δάμπογλου έχει ελευθερο χρόνο φυσιαπό το λίγο όμως που προσπάει
θα εγώπ προσπαθούμε να χρόνκλείσνούμε το δενα μην ανακλείσμε το πώτα ατυάρχει ελεύθερο χρόνο κίταξε
να δείτ ήταν μια συγκυρία ναιη οποία μας εμπόδηση πι δύο δομάδες ιμο στη διαπονία
κτηνοκολογική εταιρία τον ιαπόνο ήθελε να μετιμήσει και με εκάλεσαν ήταν ηλημμένει απόφαση υπάρχει όμως
ο ελεύθερος χνός πως άρχισε όποιείται από πλευρά σασε ένα πραδοσιακόλαμεσο άνο θα λά σας
ναι έχω ένα μικρό φουσκοτών και το εκμεταλλέύομε ποτέ έχω την δεύτερο πό την λα
δότα τις τους αγώνες της ομάδας μου που θα πάω να υκάλω εγμάλιστα και πολλά
από τα αποθημένα καμια φόρά που αφηννα φορόξου για οδιετητή πολογια τουλάισμα η ομάδα ποια
είναι ο άρλεμεσω μάρις λέμες αλλά εντάξει μέσα στα κοσμικά πλαίσια ου δε θα βρίσω
αλλά θα εκφράσ ότι της αρασκεια μου παράδωσε ακόσοβαδος το